When I share something
It is often because I felt a fleeting idea of ​​how wonderful it was.
Which means that if the participation takes longer than necessary
Press the Undo button and give up.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I'm your least favored user.
To help you create magical moments when you participate,
Android Marshmallow introduced a new feature called "Direct Share"
Direct Share can set direct engagement goals.
Which launches a specific activity in your application when the user starts to participate.
To be clear here, imagine the following situation:
If you find a new interesting article to share with my sister
You have chosen your app from the sharing dialog.
Opens your app.
that's cool.
But direct participation means that I can choose to correspond with my sister
Your application opens on this correspondence
The article waits for me in the text of the message until I click "Send".
Now, this is a good user experience.
To enable direct participation with goals,
You must define a degree that extends to ChooserTargetService
In your new service,
You need to activate onGetChooserTargets
This method presents the goals of participation to the system
So that he can put them in the dialogue of participation.
OnGetChooserTargets is where your application can upgrade as much as it wants.
Perhaps it makes more sense to show up ten more back-end messages,
Or maybe your app provides a way for users
Until they discover the people they care about most.
You can provide them with a list of close friends instead.
Or maybe you know any correspondence,
Such as mass messages, for example,
More likely to use links attached,
These are the likely objectives of participation.
This magic is due to you.
We just made our framework
So you can build a better application.
Now we need to update our publication.
As with any new service, we need to announce it,
But what's special about our ad is then BIND_CHOOSER_TARGET_SERVICE
This will allow us to interact with the system,
In order to share those underlying purposes and share the objectives well.
And of course the implicit filter that links this service as an optional service.
It covers everything you need to fill out a sharing system dialog.
But what if the user chose one of your options?
You'll want to start the appropriate activity when you open your app
To do this, you have to link those specific activities to the proper implied purposes.
So you'll need some metadata to do that,
But it's really that simple.
So to play "Direct Share" in your own application,
Look at our very interesting sample,
Which you will find in the description below.
Or check our documents.
But more importantly, he continued to build better applications.
G + Group for Android Development Click here for more
See more Android developers